ce jour que nous ne sommes pas vraiment
l'hiver c'est pour ça que vous n'avez
qu'un jour selon oui seulement ce que
nos téléspectateurs ne savent pas c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes vous n'êtes pas
là j'ai pas dit non vous êtes à londres
aujourd'hui cet exode paraît très
curieux c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que
vous y faites à londres aujourd'hui bien
je fais lui entre autres je fais trois
plats alors nommé ici en demi heure je
fais un seul de ces trois plats et en
plat que connaissent déjà les
téléspectateurs en partie car je leur ai
fait une fois les crêpes que je vais
refaire aujourd'hui mais d'une façon
tout à fait différent mais j'ai aussi
fait des crêpes frites une autre fois et
j'ai aussi fait des pommes soufflées
mais alors là nous allons nous allons un
gruyère est une synthèse du toulon fait
à la fois des pommes soufflées des
crêpes de la sauce aussi une sauce qui
s'appelle la sauce mireille c'est à dire
c'est pas tout à fait la sauce mireille
c'est un dérivé de la sauce mireille
mais tout de même
ainsi c'est aussi une sauce qui
ressemble en tout cas qui a le même
procédé de fabrication que la
hollandaise où la sauce mousseuse
par conséquent je vais redonner cette
source tout de suite et loi de façon à
ce que vous puissiez vous en aurez alors
je vais commencer que tout n'est cette
émission est filmée parce que l'on vous
a dit on leur a dit que j'apparais comme
et au rail et si vous avez maintenant il
faut qu'on fait rien alors voilà je vais
j'ai ici dans la casserole déjà une
réduction de poivre de vin blanc et
devinez un jour oui alors je rajoute
trois jaunes d'oeuf avec de l'eau ce
sport et je vais chauffer qui relance
quelle quantité de vin blanc j'avais mis
en grand bain blanc et vinaigre mélanger
c'est à dire à 2-1
c'était très réduit
j'avais seulement tester votre le
principe de la gastrique que vous
connaissez déjà pâti alors ici ne soit
jamais majoritaire dans de l'eau et 2014
et je vais péter c'est pas le petit
racer enseigné comme nous avons déjà
pris une sauce mousseuse c'est à dire je
m'en que les jaunes dans les rapports
que nous leurs occasions d'affaires il
se brouille et je suis toujours pas
faire de bruit
alors je monte les gens rapidement il
montre bien de les ajouter un peu d'eau
froide
je voudrais pas forcément ceux là voilà
un moment que tout ça ensemble les trois
jolies des oiseaux ne pourra guère de 20
de la petite histoire
ellison et russell alors je continue à
monter et voilà c'est prêt alors ici ici
je baisse le gaz n'est pas ce que j'aime
c'est différent nous sommes pas dans le
studio non dans le studio personnel
vraiment à l'hiver dans le studio
personnel mon arrivée alors ici beurre
fondu
n'est ce pas et huile l'huile mélanger
un tout petit peu d'huile d'arachide et
beaucoup d'huile de dole et c'est à dire
deux tiers duel d'olive et un tiers du
match alors nous allons dans les
jeunesses de l'anc mettre un tout petit
peu de pertes sont des voyous
environ le tiers de ceux dont nous
aurons besoin tout à l'heure je dois
changer et nous le faisons à retourner
par syngenta de convient aurez vous
besoin toute l'année
le tiers de ses mille ans nous aurons
deux fois produire que de peur nous
soyons fous consulting ans habituel si
vous voulez ça correspondait à son grand
regret de faire actuellement
voilà on le faire sauver et ménager la
route et de riz un peu plus de poids que
lui ny ai pour eux alors pour le moment
7 et poivrer fissures nous avons mis du
poivre moulu d'ailleurs nombre de
millionnaires dans la gastro il va jouer
pour lui et comme s'il s'agissait d'une
mayonnaise
il manque aussi sérieusement m c'est une
espèce de mayonnaise chaudes ont fait ça
voilà ce que votre sens interdit dans
son terrier
je devais simplement la salle et car
dieu l'est pas je n'ai pas encore ça
mais c'est simplement pas vrai alors
voici ma sauce et les terminer
voilà je ne vais pas à passer je pouvais
la facétie foulée mais ça ne lui apporte
rien ça ne fait simplement perdre du
temps je vais donc simplement corner ça
s'appelle corner car habituellement pour
faire ce travail-là collector nettoyer
le taux de magas roll avec une stature
et maintenant ma soeur c'est terminé
nous allons commencer à les occuper
décret oui mais raymond olive et vous
avez beaucoup parlé de sel mais vous
n'en avez pas mis en exergue la
catherine si vous vous lavant
l'amabilité merci ne faut jamais donner
le sein de la main il faut toujours le
posez vous prescrira c'est une
superstition
ça vient de très loin derrière c'était
trop tôt voilà ce que si elles étaient
très rares alors ne voulait absolument
pas le père et donc leur passion le
passage de laisser tomber et par
conséquence de la crise alors voilà j'ai
serré ma sauce il ya donc tout le
problème
aussi la frontière elle est terminée
vous allez voir en réunion avec là je
vais rester ici et comme je voulais vous
faire maintenant nous occupent a décrit
est bien pour l'occuper décret nous
allons commencer par si vous voulez les
pommes de terre mon notaire après j'ai
déjà fait cette recette n'est pas tous
mais je veux la refaire rapidement
derrière puisque nous sommes toujours
évité par notre ce temps alors je ve
arrt de la pomme de terre testé sur une
assiette qui nous informe de terre non
mais si je leur art comme ceci j'ai des
instruments pour affaiblir internet mais
je ne le fais pas parce que je veux
justement prouvé que l'on pouvait on
perd tout à la main et nous n'avons pas
besoin d'être humain c'est un avantage
mais un certain de notre absolument
besoin ça restait là je peux arriver à
faire devant mon émission voilà je vais
en avoir si je vais faire très peu je
devais faire que deux cantons du rap et
d'ailleurs ça donne un peu de la
boutique
c'est un peu d'amour oui c'était dur je
vais en effet en a que deux
crêpes par conséquent si janot versé
alors ici il me faut des champignons go
voilà encore des champignons et des
oeufs
c'est pourquoi encore l'exclusion
d'utiliser très souvent dans vos
recettes
c'est parfois une clope aux champignons
je peux pas le faire c'est un champion
quand même faut être logique
un jeune à remettre qu'un seul puisque
je ne veux faire que de crêpes vous êtes
bien chiche alors oui je suis chiche
d'un sauteur je vais mettre de la
muscade avec une petite frappe
évidemment qui n'est pas celle que vous
avez reçus séoul a envoyé à moi mon bref
c'est dit pas ça parce qu'il ya ma télé
pour vous je voulais pas bon alors du
poids je ne bats la toute petite
quantité vos marques
et je vais prendre du persil haché à
l'oref poivre persil haché
six cas de muscade du sel également aux
héros cette fois vous n'oubliez pas ce
ne l'oublient pas comme j'avais oublié
dans la sauce tout à l'heure et puis je
vais mettre cette pomme de terre râpées
tels que sans les sauver tous et se voit
là ça je vais laver avait pour moi je
vais donc maintenant je vais tout à leur
joie chez les champignons jeu a lâché
également très peu puisque je n'ai pas
besoin de faire beaucoup d' de crêpes
faire que de crêpes
si je n'ai fait que deux espèrent par
rapport à la quantité de choses par
rapport à ce que je ne peux pas en faire
plus je n'ai pas le temps matériel
interplus par conséquent ce sont ces
deux seulement qui m'intéresse mais je
devrais faire la recette pour 4 heures
soit environ 20 les protections à une
seule carte en question ne s'utilise une
ou deux ans comme de ceux du genre
beaucoup c'est un plat de début puisque
aujourd'hui comme toujours les dit tout
à l'heure je suis à lons et je fais
trois plats dont celui ci est le premier
ensuite y en aura
bienvenue deux autres et en oiseau sait
pas encore lequel ce sera et puis il y
aura un soufflé à souffler dans lequel
je voudrais essayer de le mettre
ni de blanc d'oeuf ni d'offres court
derrière parce que ce soit un souffle
est inhabituel il s'agit d'un concours
avec une canne anglaise qui s'appelle
elles finissent craddock ou autrement
dit madame bon hiver dans une émission
résultat la presse communiste du match
on parlera de vous soyez sans crainte
alors ces champignons h et c'est bien
c'est chapillon il sans tache et la
voilà h et j'aime rêver les essorer le
moindre se répondent oui parce que
maintenant beaucoup d'autres dont il ya
quand même beaucoup d'audace et
champignons alors je n'ai pas en torchon
et je vais les faire tomber là c'est en
cherchant dans une petite n'est-ce pas
là gamin recherche tours à recueillir
tout à l'heure le jus l'eau enfin ce
champignon voilà il a vraiment sortir du
lot même plus d'humilité parce qu'ils
sont très très frais néanmoins voyez
vous il ya un tout petit peu de bon
temps plein pour ça c'est terminé et
maintenant nous avons donc ces quelques
champignons h et que voilà
nous n'allons pas ensemble c'était le
loeuff n'est pas avec le persil haché
la pomme de terre le poivre sel le
poivre sel bien entendu tous les
abonnements à la muscade
vous n'avez pas parlé que j'ai oublié il
était pourtant sans votre petit rap
néanmoins fini le progrès voilà mes
champignons bon pendant ce temps là je
vais mettre à chauffer ma poire mais
fois les poêles à pellets suppose que
vous êtes
des crêpes alors voilà deux poêle à
crêpes aux réglages un peu plus fort un
petit pinceau dans le beurre fondu
beurrer les poils depuis un petit coup
de torchon dans l'espoir qu'elle soit
bien sèche
voilà alors je continue à faire mon
ménage et l'âge avec laquelle je vais
faire des crêpes
enfin ce sont les quatre saisons j'ai
parlé comme souffler tout à l'heure eh
bien le viendront en leur temps j'ai
raté elles viendront s'ajouter à
marseille donc je beurre les poils oui
et je vais faire deux clubs seulement
puisque nous avons dit que nous n'avons
pas beaucoup beaucoup de temps alors je
crois que ça devient un petit peu
obsédant de dire ça c'est pas utile tout
le monde sait mais c'est ce qu'on
appelle soleil apparaît l'appareil est
que le met dans la poche et les cartes
du petit peu pour la claque aussi fine
que possible avec cette séparation
cet appareil vient d'inde et mais c'est
un mot technique alors j'ai cherché les
préparations voilà alors voici ma
première grève
copé et jean croire une seconde à ma
façon
depuis hier je voyais vous l'avez
voulant faire très peu et un effectif
jeune et francophones tout c'est le
paradis est important oui j'ai mouillé
aux mélanges en fait très peu au compte
de deux crêpes j'ai vraiment peu de
choses à se faire pour deux personnes
oui bien sûr laisser cuire et puis nous
allons occuper un tout petit peu par
instant là de la pataterie y est car
nous avons aussi la pâte à frire pâte à
frire de l'or la faire à l'envers très
peu également
paris quand les séries quand tu es avant
m 3 cuillères de paris c'est pas la
peine d'être beaucoup mieux
[Musique]
faciliter leur mettre un tout petit peu
attendu contre si oui de leur côté à
côté
faire chauffer la crème ça voilà les
sont elles dans une couleur à la fois
vertes et brunes et loïc féry voilà
c'est terminé
oui on termine en quelque sort il faut
tout jeune qu'elles cuisent un petit peu
bon ça s'est terminé le rendant me soit
fiable tard initie l'informons espèces
depuis longtemps faisant sauter les
crêpes
bien entendu à vous d'y retourner
plusieurs fois oui parce que le pape et
attend que très bien repris après
l'arrêt de coquelles crise le pôle une
certaine raideur
c'est la première fois
enfin bic un ravissant là alors ça c'est
terminé
une sphère de la question ici de ceux ci
je vais dans les mettre de côté leurs
maîtres
bon nous faisons maintenant nous avons
des la pâte à frire pâte à frire comment
avec un petit peu de muscade encore que
nous aurons fait tout à l'heure si
j'avais eu la vente je serai pas tomber
largeur un petit peu de muscade par le
poivre du sel un tout petit peu et c'est
un tout petit peu de l'huile un tout
petit peu parfois le jeu un petit peu
une cuillère dorée petite cuillère je
vais mettre un oeuf entier
le voilà et puis avec un fouet c'est ici
un peu de bière que voilà je vais
maintenant et aux 1,2 milliard de bière
et moi c'est terminé
il suffit de large et menace un petit
coup de fouet la dja voilà
et voilà ma pâte à frire en grande
partie en grande partie seulement
pêcheurs falloir que tu as eu des
blenders
voyez vous voici la première partie la
pataterie et puis le met de l'argent
maintenant voici un bol c'est à dire non
valable ans passés en blanc de bassines
allons nous prenons des blancs d'oeuf
jean promettons donc trois ans n'a pas
grande importance comme ça c'est à dire
non c'est toi
jeudi outre parce que c'est pour moi
c'est pour une question de vitesse je
vais un petit peu de sel dans les stats
et d'entretien je viens d'un petit peu
de cesena et je veux dire pourquoi on
met du sel dans les dents les blondes on
met du soleil levant des fonds qu'ils
montrent mieux salle permet qu'ils ne
craignent pas et qu'ils montrent mieux
car plus les blancs d'oeufs sont frais
et je conseille les employés plus fait
que subir et un dernier
plus ils sont faits moins bien immonde
c'est un fait
oui alors nous allons les mentions et
bien là je peux ainsi commenté les
blancs des recettes de battre les pelé
blanc n'est pas le bol on ne doit pas
choisir pas entendre le fouet le volant
à la fin lorsque le pape avait entamé au
début mais c'est surtout les blancs de
la psycho bas alors il n'est pas besoin
d'ailleurs que ces vendeurs soient les
réserves pour une pâte a pris même en
cuisine on dit l'industriel attendant
les attend dans les mondes d'athènes
à peine monté c'est suffisant mais je
préfère le monde est normalement où la
beauté du corps
le monde devant moi maintenant excusez
moi de 60 et en commun je leur ai dit qu
ils ne sont pas refermées les tournées à
la montée tu peux le trouver
[Musique]
eh bien nous allons bâtisse a été la
muse
voilà nous allons mélanger comme ceci
alors j'aime beaucoup ça pourtant vous
voyez je mélange de tout un sens et j'ai
obtenu qui ne pas tarir comme le désire
et légère très bien et fait certainement
de faire appeler blanche n'a pas trop
fait trop ferme
il ne faut pas qu'il soit trop faire bon
voici une élément voici le second
élément est maintenant nous allons nous
occuper le rôle est fière d'eux cette
sauce qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue a
refroidi les investisseurs ne l'a pas
tout à fait aux foires et y intéressiez
métier alors nous avons ici une friteuse
une négresse en quelque sorte c'est
pareil [ __ ] cette année grâce toute
simple et nous allons parler les pommes
soufflées
puisque vous n'aurez avait tout à leur
demander eh bien oui voici les points et
souffle et un vaisseau tout frais tout
fait
elles sont le fait pas tout à fait elle
songe l'embauché vous savez que je vous
ai appris l'autre jour à faire les fonds
de souffler oui vous étiez la spa lane
en fait j'ai appris aux téléspectateurs
comment vider les comptes souffler voici
des pantoufles et cadets tes ailes
coupées d'une façon un peu spécial et je
vous le disais dans l'émission que j'ai
fait sur cela fonctionne la façon de
fabriquer les de faire les comptes
souple et vous dire qu'on peut leur
donner la forme que l'on veut
là j'ai donné une forme de règles de
réglettes qui va m'aider à voyons
lorsqu'elles vont être soufflée bien
comme il faut je vais plier ma crêpe
autour de ses ports en mettre une ou
deux mais pas de façon à ce que donnait
d'alléger la préparation au fond ces
pommes servent davantage à donner aérer
le plat plutôt qu'à donner du goût
puisque ne viennent en quelque sorte pas
ajouter quelque chose qui a déjà deux
pommes de terre et les champignons et
les fidjiens
c'est à dire que et de la sauce en plus
parce que c'est car il n'y a pas la
question nous donner du goût mais
surtout de donner d'alléger un tout
petit peu
bon eh bien je crois que ma future de
tracy chargement avait tenté quelques
formules ça va aller je l'entends
quelques-unes seulement j'ai pas besoin
dans des bocaux qu'on fait bien entendu
d'ailleurs vous ai dit qu'il n'y a
jamais de problème en ce qui concerne
les comptes souffre il fallait rajouter
une fois les houblons toujours comment
les autres deuxième épisode le deuxième
épisode elles ont été fauchées alors les
voilà nous allons les écouter sur une
assiette de nous en servir et au soutien
de petits bâtonnets nous sommes soufflés
ils sont très joli derrière
j'espère que l' on le voit bien
je vais pas les faire colorer car on m'a
reproché d'avoir toujours les écuyers en
réalité ce n'est pas vrai c'est parce
que la caméra évidemment d'or en tout
petit peu plus de couleurs si nécessaire
il est en réalité pour livrer
certainement bien bernard werber la paye
nous sommes très contents du arriver le
très bien
voilà alors voici mes pommes soufflées
donc dégoûté le sentez-vous tête
exactement ils n'arrivent pas venir la
chercher tout seul voilà alors nous
allons baisser de quelques minutes
oui et maintenant nous allons donc faire
ses fameuses crêpes frites
voilà une crèche je vais la poser ici et
ça sert à côté je viendrai tout à
l'heure les remettre cette assiette et
je prends un petit peu de sauce de cette
chose qui n'est pas de la sauce mirage
mais qui ressemble la sauce mireille ici
c'est je vais en tartiner légèrement
chacune des crêtes
voyez vous il ya beaucoup plus de sens
qu'il est nécessaire mais ceci parce que
normalement on doit faire ma recette
était prévu pour environ 4 personnes et
où j'aurai donc échoué écrite de classe
par personne 4 personnes c'est
exactement la quantité
je voulais dire on y entendra alors et
aux ja plati très légèrement comme ceux
ci la sauce avec une dispute et qui
n'est pas stratégique et ce avec une
cuillère bien entendu n'est pas
absolument nécessaire
voilà merci
et puis je prends donc une pantoufle et
bien souffler je prends les plus soufflé
n'est pas très disert qui j'ai le plus
joli voilà qu'elle devait plier
uniquement pour faire de l'air au centre
france a souffert de l'hérault centre je
plie la crêpe voyez vous comme ceux ci
sur elle même et je la remets là
attention doit pas me voir je voudrais
que l'on voit bien ça s'est terminé par
fois ses talents pas complet ça ça va
trop vite
le m une seconde ici on leur remettra au
chaud quand je vais être prêt dans
quelques secondes
cette sauce est terminée nous n'en
parlons plus en plus je peux la sortir
et la limace et se débarrasse là pour
donner caméra le maximum de chances de
tout saisir
voilà voilà mes deux crêpes n'est ce pas
bon eh bien maintenant je vais les faire
frire
je vais les faire frire avec une
écumoire jerry seah ce que la pêche une
araignée la friture peut-être non c'est
pourquoi c'est l'instrument de jeu par
une araignée cette araignée mais la m
voter je m'en servirai tout à l'heure
pour extraire les bons alors je reviens
au jour revient au chaud survie de gaz
très vite oui oui ça change très vite et
mon dieu c'est extrêmement pratique je
dois bien l'avouer
alors voici ma terre ce n'est ce pas
l'amb longe dans la pâte à frire cette
cuillère me gêne un tout petit peu je
l'enlève voyez-vous la temps et j'ai
l'extrait comme ceux ci en égouttant
autant possible la tuer par une spatule
pour m'aider je viens dans la friture je
pose simplement ma crêpe comme ceux ci
et vous avez avoir le temps de terminer
cinq minutes
oui oh oui fish toi même je vais si j'ai
cinq minutes encore je vais avoir du
temps de trop alors ici voyez vous je
recommence comme j'étais tout à l'heure
et je mets ma second degré dans la
future
façon voici ça s'est terminé ça s'est
terminé
et ça c'est sûr alors je prends la
l'araignée et je vais retourner après la
presse je ne ressens plus le droit
d'être aussi fougueuse il ressemble plus
à une avec une photo mais réussit alors
vg voilà voilà
et je vais les laisser cuire quelques
secondes pas trop pour le parc tout à
l'heure me disent qu'ils sont noirs
je ne peux pas pas assez même je dois
jouer à voir pouvait pas assez pas tout
à faire c'est puisque normalement faut
qu'elle soit bien bien coloré et là je
me contenterai d'une coloration moyenne
que leurs aînés on admettra une fois
pour toutes non non mais le tour de tout
seul pratiquement c'est bon signe un
concept ou symboles se retourner tout
seul alors voyez-vous là dedans vous
avez vu qu'il y avait de la sauce de la
sauce ch'ti en chauffant va devenir
extrêmement liquides qui va donc
imprégné cette crête et la pomme de
terre souple et disparaît complètement à
la cuisse or elle a complètement
disparue ayant complètement disparu
saleix en espèce de vide qui est
extrêmement daguerre va trouver parce
que ça allège une recette qui somme
toute est plutôt est plutôt un peu
lourde puisque les agiles de friture et
que chaque fois qu'ils habitent friture
c'est tout de même quelque chose d'un
tout petit peu d'eau il ya déjà eu
strictement il ya nommé après la pluie
drue messahel est très sèche n'est ce
pas là un couple est recentré certes
annick la pâte à frire absorbe une
partie de l'huile ça c'était impossible
de faire autrement et par conséquent
c'est ce qui alourdit un tout petit peu
la recette c'est certainement la
dernière lecture car là jusque là et ce
n'est pas lui c'est une recette de qui
ça ne vous étonnera d'imprimantes
originale de moyens
après bien entendu ce n'est pas parce
que les télés de moi qui est original et
lycéens savent non mais puisque
aujourd'hui souvent des risques
aujourd'hui je suis il s'agit il s'agit
d'une recette que je fais à londres et
une averse est absolument nouvelle alors
nous devons composer trois plats et
trois plats absolument nouveau c'est à
dire absolument inédit et la dame à qui
vous êtes confrontés est la personne qui
fait la cuisine les émissions de cuisine
elle fait les émissions de cuisine à la
vie ici à la bbc or je prends un petit
peu de sel jeux salle très légèrement
peut être également casse tous les trucs
mais pour la sécurité voici et je vais
dresser n'est ce pas sur une serviette
ces deux clubs ne sais pas je ne fais
pas mesquins toul meurthe et il va faire
trois ans
oui oui vous voyez alors si l'on
recommence sur un an vers le prochain
coup orange va faire 3 propose prochain
qu'est ce que vous faites la semaine
prochaine
eh bien nous allons essayer de faire
quelque chose de bien quand il s'agit
d'une émission de l'émission confirmé
aujourd'hui je donne longtemps quelque
sorte avant puisque nous sommes avant
noël en tout qui perdrait je ne pourrai
donc que vous le dire que dans le
courant de la semaine prochaine ce que
je ferai l'an dernier en dernier ressort
bien nous le serons en et souhaitons que
vous soyez victorienne alors ce concours
qui vous oppose parlons pattes ça n'a
pas de sens alors remarquer que les deux
mains sur du bois n'est ce pas sécurité
on dit je veux surtout pas
[Musique]